have a box
this was sent to me by a website
that we kind of know and love at least
so a lot of us
were actually i think they actually come
from this place
like if you're watching on twitch
at least 80 of you probably came from
here
so it's like it's it's a high quality
box
and the tape is very well stuck to the
box so i don't know should really get a
box color
oh you know i have i have a little um
clipper thing this should
cut the tape okay
i know this is really weird to be
opening something
from youtube on twitch
but twitch partner agreement i'm not
actually allowed to live stream
on youtube so
this will probably go on youtube
eventually
i'm really confused because i cut both
sides oh here we go
okay so it has a little opening thing
people can see something inside
[Music]
thanks so much well first of all okay i
want to thank everyone
for supporting the content um
i should probably be more emotional but
it's kind of late and i'm kind of tired
i'm sure people have seen videos of
other creators
getting something similar
so this is it's from youtube maybe i can
just show it
if you're watching and you want to read
this fully
yeah this was sent from susan how do we
say this name
voyage basically the ceo of youtube
i don't know if she actually signed this
it looks kind of like a
a printer thing but it says you've done
something
that very few youtube creators
accomplished you had an astonishing
100 000 people subscribed to your
channel
uh yeah thanks everyone uh this is all
of you
i think now it's actually it's probably
closer to
a hundred thirty thousand
so it goes on to say we know that
numbers on youtube can get really big
but we hope that you don't lose
sight of reality behind the six-digit
milestone
each and every person that has
subscribed maybe some people with
multiple accounts though
each and every person who has subscribed
to your channel has been touched
by what you created they were inspired
challenged or entertained
that's maybe fair to say yeah you
achieve this milestone with hard work
perseverance and probably a healthy
sense of humor too
the humor is sometimes dry but that's
okay
what you've accomplished cannot be taken
away from you
and we like to recognize you and all
your hard work with a silver
creator award a small token of our
esteem and respect
we know that you don't do this for
rewards you do it
because you have a drive to create and
share and because you've found an
audience who cares
believe us when we say that we can't
wait to see what you do next
a million subscribers may seem a long
way off right now but you're closer than
you think
and we're rooting for you
congratulations here sincerely
and then susan thanks susan i appreciate
that
i wish i knew how to pronounce her last
name
voyage wait chicky anyway
um okay so this don't want to drop it
oh i have a business card from rick
interesting anyway
um here's
what it looks like i'll have to find a
place to put this
uh but i do really want to thank
everyone i mean it's been
it's been really oh my gosh thanks so
much admiral
congratulations eric well and
here are some play button birthdays
thanks so much for the yeah the fun
birthday bits
i really appreciate that um yeah i
do want to thank everyone i mean for
just the
loads of support even for the people
that just lurk or just watch
um of course everyone who's donated
subscribed
followed engaged in the comments you
deserve at least one gazillionaire
your dry humor is the best there is
thanks so much love from berlin
richter's neighbor so i actually made my
youtube channel
when was it it was back in it was back
in 2015 i want to say
oh no i made this so i made this channel
in 2013
but i didn't start uploading
consistently until 2017
was around the time i i started with
twitch as well
and yeah it started as just a passion
project
we could go if people want to like see
the earlier videos
on my channel
okay so if we sort by like oldest
yeah the first video i ever uploaded was
seven years ago
and when i first started i was just kind
of interested in making videos but
didn't think
really didn't think it would
attract such a big audience because
chess was a pretty small niche at the
time and i made some like
kind of montage videos
the first one that really like struck a
chord was one of my first streams ever
was a beating people with tricky
openings stream number one
and at the time i think only
only one or two people were actually
watching
and actually i've had my stream open so
i counted as one of the viewers
it was a time where i was still like
really new to twitch and youtube
and wasn't so comfortable speaking like
in front of the camera
but it got positive feedback
people started to like watch
and yeah i want to thank everyone like
for being really encouraging
and it's been it's been a really fun
ride i mean i was not expecting it to
to grow this big but i mean it was fun
and
it's still it's still something i really
enjoy so i don't have any plans of like
retiring
anytime soon um and in the beginning i
put no no attention into thumbnails
or titles a lot of it was
okay maybe yeah there's one this was
probably my first
cool kind of thumbnail the streaming
with a pug
a lot of these videos still have like a
low number of views
um but it's really like i didn't really
do it for the viewership
or any sense of like an intention of
making a career out of it
it was just kind of something to do for
fun and then
it turned into to something bigger
so i'm really grateful for for every
single one of you
uh who who watch on youtube and on
twitch
shout out to twitch chat um i don't even
know what else to say
like i feel like i should have a speech
prepared
but i do appreciate
like all the positivity especially uh i
know
like in the past youtube comments
haven't had the best reputation
but i mean overall people are
encouraging helpful
i mean do provide like constructive
feedback
so yeah thanks so much stay tuned for
more content
uh if you're new to the channel feel
free to go back check out the previous
videos
especially when it like in the field of
content creation
you can do this with anyone on youtube
is to like watch their
their most recent stuff and then go back
and watch their older stuff
and kind of see how how they evolve over
time
anyway uh thanks again to everyone
and if you're watching this in the
future
on youtube uh you're you're a part of
this
let me switch let me switch back to
full video yeah i still have mona lisa
but that's okay you're you're a part of
this so thank you
you're positive youtube comments are a
reflection of the character
you display on your streams and in your
videos
oh thanks so much off the sheen
i think it's also sometime it can be a
reflection of mods too
mods can be helpful at least on twitch
but uh
yeah i might i might have to like clean
this i don't know if i can
probably not a good idea to mount this
to the green screen
yeah i'm just making sure they they
spelled my name correctly which is
which is clutch anyway yeah thanks again
um stay tuned for more like regular
content
and i'll see you in the future